well look I hate to disappoint you but
not much happen this week all right
let's go over what happened the offices
of trumps personal lawyer were raided he
had a meltdown over Jim Comey's book the
homeland security adviser quit the
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan out and
we're attacking Russia in Syria as we
speak right now so things are really
quieting down no it looked like Trump
was backing off his threat to attack
Syria but apparently he got the go-ahead
from Fox & Friends today I don't want to
say this raid is meant to distract from
his other problems but it's called
Operation Desert Storm II
we knew he was getting a serious about
the Syria because he gave us odd a
nickname this weekend you know when you
get the nickname
you know crooked Hillary lyin Ted he
calls him gas killing animal by the way
gas killing animal also headlining
Coachella this weekend we seen gas
killing animal yes this is the art of
war by Captain Underpants but but how
about that the FBI Wow moved on Michael
Cohen like a [ __ ] they raid it must
they where did it they broke down his
door you know this office his hotel room
his apartment it must mean they have
evidence of cocoa and using illegal
means to cover up Trump's affairs with
porn star stormy Daniels and playmate
Karen McDougal Watergate was followed
the money this is follow the implants
remember Michael Cohen is the guy who
said he paid paid stormy Daniels with
his own money
the legal term for this is Pro Boehner I
don't know but yeah this Muller he ain't
playing I mean they took his door off at
his office in his apartment it was like
6:00 in the morning they they banged on
the door they said are you decent he
said I work for Donald Trump what do you
Oh Trump was furious about that he said
this violates attorney scumbag privilege
but I love this I always say this I'm
not dirty the news is dirty they a new
term I learned this week tank team did
you heard this one yet because this is
not part of Muller's probe haha dirty
again but what so he sent a tank team to
Michael call that's what they call ik is
they don't want to taint it why is it
called a tame team well Trump is the
[ __ ]
the Muller is the balls and you do the
math okay so
taystee I can't write this anyway but
that was just the prelude to getting him
Bank angry because then Jim Comey's book
is coming out and I guess they already
have it at the White House and call me
compares Trump to a mob boss I don't
know about that but I do know the 2016
election fell off a truck and apparently
in the book Comey says that Trump is
just obsessed with the P tape now if you
haven't been I'm not dirty the news is
big if you haven't been following this
in the in the steel dossier which is
where a lot of this comes from he says
that Trump was in Moscow with the
Russian hookers and something mama pig I
don't it's but Trump's Oh Trump is
obsessed every time he would talk to
call me he would ask about the P take it
and Trump at one point said to call me
there's no way I would let people pee on
each other around me no way
I let Putin shut down my throat yes and
then I love this he says to Kobe Jim can
you imagine me hookers yes I can imagine
you murdering hookers it's like I could
imagine you naming hookers to the
Supreme Court
I couldn't imagine you asking Ivanka to
dress like a hooker
there's no part of a hooker plus Trump
that I can't imagine but just to show
he's not a hard-hearted man he said
Xiaomi says it bothered Trump a lot that
he was worried that Melania would think
those rumors were true and you know that
that breaks a white heart when she finds
out that the man she loves is pissing on
someone else all right or watching
something pee on someone or whatever it
is you do to make America great or even
worse what if it got back to stormy you
know so but I love this excuse that
Trump gives to Comey about why it
couldn't have been him with the P tape
he says I'm a germaphobe now most guys
would say you know I'd never do that I'm
married no Trump's excuse I'm a health
nut look at me my body's a temple
being in bed for Christ's sake that's
rape by cheeseburgers